i've never played the original play gink
but i've seen a lot of requests for this
and this is actually a really popular
video game for players wanting a quick
game no one washes their hand
researchers doctors don't work sick
people give hugs
normal
67.3 percent of people wash their hands
doctors work three days a week sick
people ignored
brutal compulsive hand washing doctors
never go home sick people locked in
prison
mega brutal genetic drift impacts
evolution doctors invest in research
random medical checkups i guess
let's do casual just to get a quick game
to learn how this bad boy works name
your plague d m
dash
v
four
i don't know why before but now it
sounds scary all right you are a new
bacteria to win you must evolve and
spread across the world wiping out all
humans in the ultimate plague select
start location select the country to
begin your plague when you select it
with the r2 button you can see more
information pop the start bubble with r2
to confirm or select another country
instead use the left stick to move the
crosshair okay
world population 7.1 billion where
should we start this
i feel like i don't want the plague to
kill anyone on the northeast coast of
the united states so i won't start there
you know what
let's target the motherland
russia population 160 million there's
planes there's ships it's rainy it's
snowy
lots of leaves dmv4 has infected its
first human weak
but used to cold temperatures it must
evolve using dna points to infect more
people i've infected one person with
zero dead there's airplanes flying all
around okay if i do blood one gives
organism abilities split to blood to
blood contact water one pathogen can
survive outside in fresh warm water
that's definitely not good for russia
because there's no warm water air one
gives pathogen ability to travel on dust
particles common fleet no we don't want
rodents birds
insects
i say blood through blood contact
that's probably the best for russia oh
symptoms painful cysts containing
pockets of the pathogen slight chance of
bursting which can spread disease and
that costs two dna points i currently
have three
let's evolve
look at that evolving happening you have
spent dna points to evolve your disease
and more options have opened up get more
points by popping dna in biohazard
bubbles with r2 and infecting people i
don't get oh
i popped oh i just got dna points okay
time to make this a bloodborne pathogen
yeah oh this is gonna be bad okay dm4
has infected hundreds of russia
increasing the chance that infected
person will infect a healthy person keep
evolving your disease cool see i want to
go for blood too
because then we can infect bodily fluids
and get mucus membranes going it's going
to be like the flu we're going to make
dmv4 like the flu but with cysts
this is really weird oh
i like this if they can get an abscess
pockets of infected flesh are painful
and act as breeding grounds for the
pathogen increasing infection sites yeah
oh we got abilities pathogen evolves
yes
we need cold resistance because in
russia it's freezing trust me on this
i've never thought i would be so excited
about infecting the world
dmv 4 has infected thousands in russia
people are being infected faster and
faster yeah 22 000 23 000 okay oh
medicine in norway slowing infection
norway is a wealthy country with high
quality healthcare to spread faster you
may need to involve evolve the drug
resistance ability norway you got good
healthcare but i'm coming dmv4 is
beginning to spread around the world hit
the triangle button to see which
countries are infected wow look at that
we got norway finland russia ukraine
turkey iran kazakhstan china i'm gonna
create drug resistance to make sure
norway doesn't start catching up to me i
already got a mil 2 million infected dmv
dmv4 has infected more people in the
world than tb it is a very infectious
disease my god look at the country being
wiped out 21 million people two dead
i've claimed my first victim this is
making me happy for a really strange
reason russia is the first to instruct
doctors to begin research into a cure
for dmv4 the more scary dmv4 becomes by
hurting and killing people the harder
humans will try and cure remember this
one involving your disease oh no we have
a million dead as a result of my illness
russia exterminates pigeons what what's
happening in russia here oh my god look
at the government
is dispensing bottled water
exterminating rask rats face masks are
being distributed exterminating pigeons
what do the pigeons do my god russia's
dropped already two thousand dollars on
medical research that's not that much
money russia you could do better oh
oppo got a case in the u.s
do we have a case in the u.s oh 17
infected all right poor russia is just
all right on this map greenland is about
to be wiped out am i going to destroy
the population of russia right now
90 of their population is infected 10 of
their populations dead all hospitals are
closed they're using mass graves
jesus oh it's spreading into africa and
australia okay i think i'm taking over
i think the world's about to end killed
more than the black plague we've killed
over 75 million people tip fight the
cure there are two ways to fight
development of the cure evolve
aggressive symptoms to destroy countries
more noticeable or evolve cure
resistance less noticeable oh the cure
in the u.s for dmv 4 is 25 complete no
way
research doctors all over the world are
completely focused on developing a cure
no indonesia is leading the global cure
effort they started to send research
teams
pop blue bubbles to destroy their
research stop doing research
they may find a cure
this might be problematic because i
think i infected all the countries and i
think i was too aggressive with it oh
the cure of the world is 70 done you
know what i need to do i need to create
warm resistance so it can spread to
africa let's see if i can get it to
spread to africa the cure is 95 complete
i've only killed 362 million people the
cure for dmv4 is finished and is being
deployed worldwide no look at the number
of infected the world has survived a
devastating plague and will soon
eradicate dmv4 forever large numbers of
people have died and the world has
changed forever no
this is so sad no one's
officially infected
dmv4 has been eradicated
there's no way i'm gonna finish playing
this game without dmv4 taking over the
world
it's the most obnoxious honk in the
history of hunks dmv5 there's gonna be
fire
[Music]
extra
edit name dmv
five
we're going right for the u.s
because i know the u.s weakness i know
the way to make this happen
i have my white coat we're going to make
a cure impossible that's the goal this
is all going to be about fighting the
u.s ability to create a drug i already
know the strategy we're gonna keep the
symptoms mild keep the resistance on
high
ain't nobody stopping us now i feel like
that's a popular song ain't no stopping
us now
boom demonetized genetic hardening yes
look see no one's even ready for this
they think they're going to cure it with
their money ain't no money going to stop
us because i'm going to genetically
harden this medicine
beyond cures bacterial resistance 2 yes
please penguin spontaneously combusts in
zoo
i'm kind of getting hot with a slab coat
but it's okay honestly the eyeglasses
help the most because i can see oh no
let's do bacterial resistance three
bacteria survives in all climates minor
disease spreading in a normal checkup a
doctor in the usa named dr mike i'm just
kidding found a new disease which has
been named dmv5 it appears mostly
harmless but must be investigated usa
starts to work on cure okay us i see you
look at this genetic hardening good luck
dna us
with your
research dollars okay so it's spreading
pretty quickly the deaths are gonna
skyrocket if i do pneumonia but if you
have a lot of deaths and they're gonna
put more money into the cure so i don't
wanna do that just yet
you gotta be strategic if you want your
virus to destroy the world okay here we
go this is where this is where i'm going
to strike
transmission you ready let's do insects
oh my god that insect thing is going to
put us over the edge
oh yeah
oh yeah
okay let's let's do another insect all
right we're definitely gonna take over
look at that spread in canada okay let's
do uh bloodborne transmissions who now
oh my god oh we're gonna get the entire
world infected with this more people in
the common cold it's the ultimate
infectious disease they're one percent
to a cure good luck vomiting boom let's
hit him with the vomiting let's hit him
with the pneumonia watch the number of
dead skyrocket right now look at that 36
000 95 000 dead let's put paranoia in
there let's do seizures how about we do
a little genetic reshuffle research
doctors all around the world are
completely focused on finding a cure for
me oh no the cure is 50 complete i can't
lose this again oh the cases in
greenland are spreading look at that
look at that look at that look at that
that looks so good
oh my god yes there are no healthy
people left in the world we all have
tmv5 yeah oh no they're at 83
oh no come on with all these symptoms
how are people not dying faster
projectile vomiting okay cool cool cool
cool cool never thought i would say that
6.2 million people are dead 6.3 billion
6.4 billion this is the most evil i've
ever been in my entire life but i'm here
for it 27 million people left alive
7.1 billion people dead oh my god it's
to destroy humanity the last few humans
know that they are watching the end of
history 300 000 people 200 000
100 000 80 000 16 000 50 000 30 000.
i've never been so excited for humanity
to seize existence
five thousand people three it's like new
year's
i've killed
everyone on earth dmv5 has successfully
eliminated all life on earth that's what
i was talking about just needed my
stethoscope my lab coat and my glasses
if you enjoyed watching me play play
game i'm sure you're gonna enjoy this
playlist of me playing other games and
if you have suggestions drop them down
below in the comments stay happy and
healthy